Wait, you didn't change your character?
yeah I did
no I can't see you're just white
*whaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaat*
Dude I got, I'm a police officer
No! I'm the police officer
I'mmm THE POLICE OFFICER
HAHAHA(Oh so funny right?,haha jk)
I spent so much time customizing this character
*breathless laugh*
It's almost like
HEY HEY! HEY!
-(laughs) Oh yeah!
-Excuse me
Excuse me!
No, thank you.
We just started playing
-I want to look at my character
-oh, ohhhhhh
Let's get going Ken
let's go, lead the way.
Follow the police officer
Can--can I get in here?
Yeah, yeah, of course
-*laughs*
-Of course you can, eh
What do you think, this is some stupid game
where you can't
Come on, oh oh oh ohh!
Ohhhh!
-Ohhhh!
-It's like um...
I'm like I'm wasted.
I'm wasted in the club dancing
Yeah gurllll
You're grinding boy
Space
press space
WHAT the hell?
OH YEAHHH
That's bullshit
-OOOOOOH
-How do you do...?
Oh
Oh yeah--I just pulled the mouse down when I had it grabbed
-Then he did the handstand
-*gasps*
Oh
No you can't get in here, it's mine
Get out of here
Let me, let me help you friend
Ayyy, thank you
Oh yeahhhh, no problem now
oooooh
You like this?
I wish I could see you, cuz I look fucking insane.
I would--I wouldn't be able to see--I wanna look at myself
so great
oh
No. no.
bruh.
no.
bruuuh
ah, no.
SAVE ME!!!
NO!NO!
LET GO.
LET GO OF ME
Save meeeee
I'm trying to save you, I swear!
Don't let go
I'm not letting go
never anything in the world
Ever!
Come on!
come on!
*sings titanic music*
Whoa!
Oh you...
you let go
Oh I see
Oh!
Aye
*laughs* AYEE
Whoa!
bow down before the true--
the true police officer
*laughs*
-YEAHAHA, YEAH
-ay, ay ay ay
How do I get up?
How do I get...
NO NO NO
AHHH
OH NOOO
GAAAAAAHHH
Hey there's a new level here
oh wait?
what the fuck?
YEAHHHH
I'm so confused
BOOO POOM, ah
fuck this
man I'm out
I forgot
you can pull stuff
look
ohhhhh
HOHOOOO
So dumb
nice
That's all we got to do--oh my God
Oh! I was like what if we climb on top of it
but never mind you're a genius
I know
I'm in--I'm on it.
HUUUP
I'm helping
You're doing a good job.
-That way!
-Thank you so much
-Oh, thank you
oh my god, nope
*laughs*
I did it
I solved it everybody
Just gotta wiggle
-help me
-just--
TWERK THAT! so violent.
Let me get behind that, girl
GOD DANG
No, no.
-Don't objectify me!
-WOO YEAH
-YEAH GURL
-stop
stop
-Made it clapping with no hands
-HELL YEAH MAN!
How you gonna get on it now?
Can you reach?
-Can you make that jump?
-CATCH ME!
*laughs*
Can you make this?
-Are we supposed to go up here?
-Oh, wait
what the fuck?
I don't think we were supposed to pull it all the way
DAGHHH
Oh, fuck's sake
-actually, actually
-gonna make it
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it
I got it
You got it?
(It was at this momement...
he knew he fucked up)
*laughs*
You did it
you did it boy!
Hey! Ay, Ay, Ay, Ay
No touchy
grab...grab my face
with both your hands
okay
grab my face
NOOO
NOOOOOOO
UH
what the fuck are you doing?
I'M STUCK
NOOOO
God dammit Ken
if only you could see it
What?
I can just key out
or Brad can just key out
like any white
The whole level is white
Hey, you're right
give it up a double hi---hi--
give me ten, Ken
Ten? I only got...?
Hell yeah
Yeah! Yeah!
Now let go of me
let go of me
let go of me, let...
DWAAAAAH
HYUUUU
BODY SLAM!!!
POOOOOH
OH
YEAH
god damn boy
...in my crotch
Good. Good. Good.
Now we have to do this again.
Hope you're happy
WHOAAHAHAHA
what the fuck?
I gotta get a zoom up. I gotta get a zoom--
It looks like your bra
like your eyes are your bra or some shit
Step up bruh.
Step up.
Oh you let him walk stepping on your hands, bruh
Alright, if you answer this question you get the blimp
Okay.
Who's the best youtuber?
Jake Paul
-YOU WIN!
-I must be right
-*laughs*
-I MUST BE RIGHT!
YESSS
-I DID IT!
-god dammit
the game doesn't laught at...
-there we go
-OH NO!!
NO!!! WHAT!!!
Ay, what the hell?
-that's it?
-ayeee
give me a squish
you want me to smash bruh?
let me smash
WOOOO
-I'm--I'm strong enough
-Hold it up with your strength
I'll hold it up
core strength
-I need--
-core body strength
no problem
push it
I'm pushing
Do it
You gotta hold it down
no fear
is it the red button?
No fear
Oh yeah
-LIMBO!
-no fear
no fear
I feel great
*laughs*
pushing the button, it won't go down any further
Ahhh
Ahhhhhh
-Ah fuckkkk
-I will always miss him
AHHHH
AHHH HELP
NO
Get back in there!
You ass
-Your not allowed to come out
-AHHHHHH
AHHHHHH
FUCK
*laughs*
AHHHHHHHH
Ah it really hurts, it stings
It stings. It fucking stings
so stings so hard
AHHHHHHHHHHHH
OH NOOOOO
NOOOOOOO
WHERE'D YOU GO?!!!!
-Oh please...don't touch me
-Surprise
please, no, no, no, no, no
no, no, no
no
-get out of here
-no
no
NOOOOOO
-My (???)
-FUCKIN ASSHOLE!
You wanna go, bro?
Bro, step up
step up
HAH MY ASS
MY ASSSSS
I don't care about your...
-AH that hurts
-COME HERE
my left cheek
GET OUT
GO
-GAAAAA
-God it hurts so...but stings
AHHHHHH
FUCKKK
AHHH My other cheek
Ah right in the crack
-AHHHHH
-ahhhhhhh
-AHHHHHHHH IT HURTS
-I AM YOUR FATHER!!!
ahhh that wedgie
KENTALITY
bend over
yeah?
No, no, no Y.
press Y
Y?
-ughhh
-very good
okay, then, grab...grab the ass
and then
AHHH MY ASS
-no, no, no you're good bro
-AHHHHHH GOD
you're good bro
There you go!
Rose you're flying!
AHHHHH YEAH
Yeah you did it!
OHHH WOW
-You're so good at this game
-now give me--
-YEAH!
-Oh, thank you
-you are the champion
-thank you
-YEAH!
-Champione
-Yes
-You're the best
-I did it
-Wow!
oh wait, I got it
-you did it
-aw hell yeah
-aw wow
I CAN'T GO THROUGH THO!!
NOOOO!!!
OPEN IT UP!!!!
Come back...
I'm so parched in this desert
So be careful, okay
let's play this
so parched
What the fuck does parched mean?
Jeez, I'm really parched.
I really perched (good job pewds)
-Ah I'm so parched
-parched right now--
No, no, no.
Let go of my ass
-Let go of my...
-you like that?
Let go of my ass
Never
-your--
-I gotta drink the juices
I'm so parched
No
-No
-Get over here!
I'm cured everybody
BLAAAAAAH
Easy
you did it!
I did it! Look!
You did it
look I did it
let me help
YEAHHH
-YOU'RE DOING IT!
-We did--
WE DID IT!
-GOD DAMMIT
-I'm so parched
AHHHHH
DANG GURL
OOOOOHHHH
YESSSS
YESSSSSS
Yes
God so hot
you like that?
OHHHH
AHHHH IT
STINGS
Raise your arms cuz I'm gonna go high.
oh, you go high?
-Yeah I go high. There you go
-I catch you, I catch you
Promise?
I promise, I catch you
You promise?
I promise.
All right
Okay, I catch you, I catch you
you catch me?
I catch you, I catch you
Not like last time?
I mean
you jumped like a sissy last time
*gasps*
You calling me a sissy?
motherfucker?
HAAAA
-YESSS
-OHHH
PLEASE DON'T LET GO
OH MY GOD
MY HERO
my hero
-thank you
-we did it
we did it
-yes
We did it
Oh?
-OH OH
-nonononono
NOOOOO
NOOO
*lizard noise*
UHHH
-that was a close one
-OH, OH
oh my god
oh
oh, I'm parched
-oh, yes
-I'm parched
so parched right now
I catch you
Yeahaha
into my arms